как захватывать внимание людей то нужно
сегодня обычному человеку чтобы он о
себе заявил биткоин может упасть банки
могут разориться А внимание никогда я
отписался в социальных сетях от всех в
ноль мы Не шутим как раньше про Пугачёву
или Филиппу киркову есть только то что
приближает к моим меня к моим целям или
делает меня счастливее блогеры вайнеры
они налога не платят люди просто Я
создаю этот масштаб То есть это большое
количество людей даже если тебя уже 200
подписчиков ты уже имеешь влияние Ну
надеюсь когда-нибудь вещество станет
большинство Приветствую друзья Сегодня
мы снимаем очередной выпуск нашего гемба
подкаста прошел месяц после предыдущего
гема подкаста Сегодня у нас не менее
интересная тема тема нашего гема
подкаста сегодня внимание как ресурс
современного мира звучит конечно немного
формально как ресурс современного мира
можно просто назвать внимание и все но
на самом деле внимание является сегодня
основным ресурсом
[музыка]
итак по традиции каждый гость у нас
представляется сам слева направо
начинаем поехали Всем привет Меня зовут
Влад Я маркетолог
Всем привет Меня зовут Я являюсь
основательницей проекта Степь это
дистрибью тут Медиа а именно мы создаем
контент для разных социальных сетей меня
зовут Марго Я ведущий сегодняшнего
подкаста Меня зовут ерболаппетильхам Я
музыкант продюсер Меня зовут Марат Урал
газин я сценарист продюсер ведущий
контентмейкер
[смех]
Сегодня я чувствую У нас гости это те
люди которые не понаслышке знают что
такое популярность не понаслышке знают
как раскачивать свой бренд И вообще
работать со своим брендом и мне первый
вопрос Вообще Как вы считаете
внимание что по вашему мнению Что такое
внимание
Внимание это как бы и сказали это на
данный момент самый важный ресурс
Внимание это по сути это наши мысли то
есть куда направлены наши мысли о чем мы
думаем ну человек Вообще я так понимаю
насколько я понимаю он как бы какой-то
определенный момент в голове может
держать только одну мысль то есть Куда
направлена Эта мысль Куда направлена его
эмоции мысли суждения там и находится
сила на самом деле куда человек
направляется свою внимание
соответственно мысли энергию
[музыка]
там и сила Ну я считаю что сейчас
Внимание это действительно самый важный
ценный ресурс и собственно все что
происходит сейчас вокруг нас это борьба
за внимание Битва за внимание
собственно Внимание это наверное тот
ресурс который формирует человека
куда он направляет внимание в эту
сторону развивать Здесь даже внимание
тире эмоция Да чтобы завлечь внимание к
себе человек такой смог посмотрел такого
Мне это нравится все сложнее и сложнее
на самом деле сейчас создавать такой
контент отличаться И на самом деле такой
Челлендж для креаторов То есть как
блогеры конференсеров и для Медиа То
есть ты постоянно должен придумать
что-то очень крутое чтобы люди обращали
на твой проект внимание поэтому
я согласна в части того что это самая
ценный ресурс потому что Bitcoin может
упасть банки могут разориться А внимание
никогда поэтому это для меня внимания
больше наверное ответственность Я хочу с
другой стороны начать
очень больно бывает когда ты не готов к
этому внимание
Вот я так уже 24 года на сцене нахожусь
вообще во всем этом понимании и когда ты
не готов что-то несешь или что-то
какую-то информацию даешь людям и они
оказываются совсем по-другому трактуют
это и ты понимаешь последствия что это
может превратиться поэтому очень важно
чтобы вести ответственность за это
внимание и вот почему
это не просто так это если мы сейчас
говорим о энергии а музыка это же
энергия
объединяет и то что сейчас вы говорите
банки биткоины на самом деле это все мы
энергия мы понимаем что совокупности там
и все энергии мы должны понимать Во что
она будет превращаться почему сейчас
люди сейчас индивидуально пытается стать
блогером или как-то мы голодный
истинным потому что все это цивилизация
которая нынешняя что у нас есть она
как-то вело нас совсем другую степь
просто наверное какие-то деньги наверное
какие-то не те правильные ценности ушли
и мы сейчас хотим найти себя как
человечности что ли что-то такое И это
больше как бы духовная часть Так как
музыкант естественно это я слезами
продукт Я занимаюсь этим все это свою
жизнь Я уже понимаю насколько это важно
самое главное хочу сказать чтобы люди
были больше ответственны вот очень
классно сказано что внимание это не
осязаемое что-то не осязаемое
глубокий человек
еще очень немаловажный аспект обратить
на себя внимание другой вопрос удержать
[музыка]
Это же было громко очень громко большое
количество скачивания в итоге вот там
сколько три недели и уже не такое
количество Дайте шанс
смотрите хорошую вы затронули такие
аспекты и была тоже хорошо дело в том
что смотрите внимание Я расценю как
Внимание это
особый механизм концентрации времени и
энергии внимание не бывает отдельно
время отдельная энергия это концентрация
времени энергии Как вот В крайних
горячая холодная вода вот краник это
внимание а горячая вода Это энергия
холодная вода это время дело в том что
мы люди Мы биологические существа
энергетические сгустки которые живут во
времени
вот в определенном промежутке времени
соответственно когда мы уделяем что-то
внимание Мы этому посвящаем свою жизнь
Мы посвящаем время мы посвящаем энергию
И когда я была говорит что нужно нести
ответственность за то внимание которым
ты на себя привлек по сути Это вся куча
людей отдала кусочки своей жизни тебе и
на тебе ответственность как ты
распорядишься и жизнями именно в данном
отрезке времени еще больше хочется
[смех]
что смотрите если ваш последователь
будет грешить то этот вина будет на тебе
А если он грешил Глядя на тебя сетевые
маркетинг в то же время если он сделал
хорошие вещи Глядя на тебя тогда тоже
Салават Ну то есть благо будет приходить
на тебя поэтому это про ответственности
про ответственность когда ты взял что-то
Внимание это на самом деле ты взял Чью
вот мы недавно приехали с багитура и я
там ребятам говорю вот мы 7 дней вместе
провели по сути мы провели Мы посвятили
свои семь дней друг другу мы посвятили
от А как по-другому назвать мы утром
просыпались вместе засыпали вместе целый
день болтали вместе все наше время и
энергия направлена была друг на друга
поэтому Внимание это время и энергия то
по сути это и есть наша жизнь наша жизнь
она
в виде энергии проживает во временном
измерении маркон калеч вы сказали очень
правильно и важно наверное вещь про то
что сейчас очень много информации везде
Абсолютно То есть ты просыпаешься
информация начинается условно грубо
говоря
если серьезно то из-за того что очень
много информации человеческому мозгу
тяжело усвоить поток поэтому что мы
делаем почему сейчас очень вывозите
очень многих предпринимателей походы не
только потому что коллективным легче
воспринять питать все то что происходит
в мире и человеку нужен человек в этом
плане я согласна часть того что это
ответственность большая потому что
с этим же надо уметь справиться это же
большой стресс помимо Вот сайт FX того
что социальные сети мы ведем это же ведь
буллинг в том числе это же небезопасно
Ну по крайней мере я лишний раз там
задумываюсь о том как где я должна
делиться там пост локации не только ведь
это помимо всего прочего это нужно быть
морально к этому готовым на самом деле
можно здесь я кое-что скажу еще опять я
с другой стороны начинаю действительно
когда грубо говоря Третья Мировая война
это информационная война Я чувствую что
это война как будто я каждый день
просыпаюсь и воюю против меня весь мир
информации и очень сложно грубо говоря
воспринимать Что правда что не прав Это
называется манипуляция для меня
манипуляция это просто неприемлемый
продукт как будто что-то там лежит
известность для человека
неизвестность И как ты это будешь делать
Тем более когда ты понимаешь что ты как
бы занимаешься именно этим продуктом и
твоя платформа социальная сеть которая
через этот и зарабатываешь деньги ты
понимаешь Вот реально не хватает силы
Как это объяснить силы чтобы дальше даже
что-то делать здесь
вот
Пользуясь случаем я хотел вопрос задать
вам это объясните мне честно говоря 50
процентов вот я хочу что-то сделать 50
процентов Я не уверен потому что сама
структура для меня не понятие само
социальная сеть для меня это что-то
неизвестное и когда мне не говорят что
это вот
блогеры вайнеры они налоги не платят мы
платим и соответственно вот это все хаос
превращается как нам быть
Здесь очень важно Я считаю такую вещь
понять
а вот я себе как ответил на этот вопрос
В свое время когда я начал писать в
социальных сетях начал я с Фейсбука я на
самом деле начал писать как для себя
писать дневник думаю классная вещь Через
много лет я буду читать свой ленту и как
будто дневник в онлайн Дневник но потом
это начало нравится людям люди начали
читать комментировать и так далее так
далее я начал писать больше больше и в
какой-то момент я понял такую вещь что
существует огромная сеть в которой куча
фейков куча плохих вещей которые в мире
существуют несчастье бед и так далее так
далее я подумал так я выставлю свой
образ жизни свой пример свои мысли свой
образ жизни Это как если это
идеологическая война
то я должен вот здесь занять свое место
чтобы на моем месте не стал какой-то
негодяй соответственно я вы чем-то я в
этот мир просто транслирую свой взгляд
Почему свой взгляд транслирую свои мысли
и свой образ жизни Почему Потому что я
не хочу пускать на самотек то как каким
будет завтрашний мир Я хочу чтобы
завтрашний мир был более Дружелюбный для
меня более понятный так как я вижу и
соответственно моя задача Я выхожу Я на
самом деле в социальных сетях работу как
пейджер Я только в одну сторону
транслирую и не обращаю внимание что там
пишут про меня не имеет значения вообще
я свою идею и так далее поэтому для меня
например видение социальных сетей и
захват внимание других людей это
донесение моего образа жизни Вот теперь
с другой стороны мы говорим Как
трансляторы как созидатели
контента вот теперь с точки зрения
потребителя контента Как настроить
фильтр так скажем своего внимания чтобы
в это поле попадало правильная
информация и как определить хорошие это
или плохое например
критическое мышление Да вот например
сейчас нас наверное смотрят в основном
обычные люди которые занимаются другими
вещами полезными для общества но в их
информационное поле попадает и
правильная информация и неправильной
информации и манипуляции какие-то как
вот в этом вот бушующим информационном
мире определить что хорошо что плохо
быть свое и двигаться именно по этой
парадине например с каждым
и если идеализировать всю эту историю и
говорить что нужно учить детей со школы
на самом деле вот финских школах Я знаю
точно обучают детей со школы на
журналистике и по крайней мере Дают
возможность
высказать свое мнение и проанализировать
его Ну вот к сожалению я что вижу сейчас
почему вот цыгане и многие блогеры
действительно перехватывают внимание
думающих людей умных людей Почему Потому
что также легче мозга воспринимается все
это легко и еще раз повторюсь мозг
устроен Так что он идет привычным путем
поэтому когда мы даже детей свою же
аудиторию как Обучаю чему-то
определенному то уже этой массы в этой
массы людей есть своя джент в голове Ну
то есть своя какая-то парадигма мнения
Ну и поэтому я согласна с вами что нужно
не то чтобы создавать себе кумиров по
крайней мере больше людей и думающих и
неравнодушных Иначе мы проиграем эту
войну и ругала Так что вы не стесняйтесь
Зря вы
много думаете над тем потому что вы
сделали очень много для нашей страны в
том числе Спасибо я не то чтобы
комплименты вам хочу сделать но я просто
говорю про то что пока вы сидите долго
думаете другие 10 человек уже создают
такой контент которого страшно мне
понравилось как мыть МакКонахи сказал
рано или поздно Мы все уйдем и он
написал про себя хорошую книгу зеленый
свет и он сказал круто будет написать о
себе книгу где я сам проживаю эмоции Я
могу рассказать их искренними нежели
потом кто-то будет говорить в третьем
лице за меня то есть грубо говоря вот он
был хороший человек Вот у него были
такие сложности но никто не знает как я
пережил эти сложности то есть вот я к
соцсетям отношусь к книге Я даже после
этого сказал своим родителям Напишите
книгу о себе потому что я со своей
стороны знаю Да вот вас было такое
детство там то я не знаю что вы
проживали Это очень интересно
вот касательно критического мышления и
того там как с этим справляться и так
далее Я считаю самое главное здесь и
чему надо учить детей это прежде всего
социальные сети из вреда превращается в
пользу при условии что у тебя есть цель
когда у тебя или у ребенка есть цель Он
не откликается на все остальные вещи
просто смотрите когда у китайской
пословицы есть у корабля у которого нету
цели не бывает попутного ветра так и
здесь когда у тебя нету цели и ты не
знаешь что ты хочешь от жизни то тебя
отвлекает все тебя все отвлекает ты
залез на 5 минут в YouTube там были
в Инстаграме через 4 часа я все
отвлекает Я например делал у себя так я
отписался в социальных сетях от всех в
ноль Потом на бумаге написал сферы своих
интересов потом по ним выбрал лучшие
экспертов и на них подписался все моих
социальных сетях нету ни пожаров не
изнасилование грабежей не убить ничего
нет есть только то что приближает меня к
моим целям или делает меня счастливее
все программы на самом деле
это при условии что у ребенка
а если нету цели то никакой критическое
мышление не поможет да то есть то есть
должна быть какая-то задача Ну то есть
цель есть остальное автоматически просто
сбрасывать все Заходим в соцсети я себе
начал задавать просто вопрос один что я
сейчас здесь делаю Вот что сейчас я
делаю и зачастую у меня уже есть ребенок
что сейчас делали пытаясь отдохнуть Тем
самым я же обманываю себя мозг вообще не
отдыхает когда контент смотрит это обман
и Второй ответ у меня был насмотренность
то есть смотрю какие-то интересные кейсы
рекламы просто для себя и когда ты
сейчас здесь делает это сложный вопрос
Ты у тебя уже идет понимание блин Выйти
отсюда или просто сидеть то есть просто
задать себе вопрос зачем ты просто
скролишь ленту я как мама можно
15-летнего подростка должна сказать что
конечно помните первое время мы очень
сильно переживали то что много
социальных сетей что дети наши залипают
это же объективная реальность нужно уже
использовать соцсети в свою пользу
скажем так и например для меня было
откровением когда она много что узнала
как раз таки из тик тока И в этот момент
я просто поняла Окей Она потребляет
много информации на что для себя
оставляет что-то нет но избегать этого и
говорить что это всегда плохо тоже
неправильно потому что
слушайте мы делаем сейчас все мы делаем
бизнес социальных сетях мы живем мы
вдохновляемся и многое другое вот
поэтому здесь вопрос такой
обучать наверное этому как сделать так
чтобы социальные сети либо Медиа были
полезны тебе Да ну то есть
мне тоже ребенок он смотрится вначале
как бы запрещал ну настроил определенный
фильтр но тем не менее запретить целиком
в любом случае
Физически невозможно получает информацию
оттуда то есть он может на определенные
темы поговорить со сверстниками То есть
если этого нет буквально точек контакта
нету да поэтому здесь тоже надо надо
понимать Ну я я благодарен потому что
у меня ребенок благодаря социальным
сетям научился писать читать 4 года То
есть я сижу он мне приходит есть такой
замечательный мультфильм Фиксики
я пишу поисковике Фиксики
Через два дня прихожу он уже на память
эти буквы нашел
следующий раз уже сам пишет телешоу
четыре года он уже благодаря поисковику
начал писать и читать ну как бы польза
очень много но как бы
я еще раз возвращаясь к целям
нож же тоже он может быть орудием
убийства можно морковку почистить
зависит от целей все зависит от цели
социальные сети тоже благо или зло
зависит от целей если ты используешь во
благо найти себе нужную информацию
партнеров или сделать бизнес и так далее
это супер инструмент просто История
человечества такого инструмента не было
в то же время если убить время это лучше
убийца времени
зависит от ваших целей и я считаю очень
важно самого детства детей все-таки
приучать к достижению цели чтобы они
четко могли проявить Что они хотят в
этой жизни
и тогда они у них будет и критическое
мышление правильное использование
социальных сетей и так далее
[музыка]
спонсоры Партнер нашего сегодняшнего
выпуска компания Marin Health с
биодобавками оши-таба это растение
многолетнее семейство сельдереевых оно
является крупным многолетним растением и
это биодобавка способствует здоровью
клеток борется с возрастными
заболеваниями и предотвращает старение
знаете я сам не рекомендую то что сам не
применяю поэтому я активно применяю эту
биодобавку и вам также рекомендую если
вам интересно то описание посылки внизу
под видео Будьте здоровыми и счастливыми
друзья
[музыка]
вообще вот смотрите Давайте вернемся
все-таки к феномену внимания
внимание вообще как захватывать внимание
людей это много многих людей интересует
Особенно тех кто хочет стать популярным
тех кто хочет начинающий блогеры и так
далее Поделитесь своим опытом своей
историей как или какие фишки в вашем
случае сработали или какие вещи
раз и вы проснулись
я если Разрешите я расскажу свою историю
для меня всегда было контент который не
просто через меня который я это пишу как
человек
а считаю что музыка это зеркало общество
Что такое понятие хит в музыке да мы
должны угадать настроение общества грубо
говоря мысли собрать А чтобы именно это
почувствовать Ты должен уйти от своего
мысля как человек единый соответственно
Я всегда Обучаю моих детей чтобы Именно
они смогли выйти куда-то туда Ну 1 вот
чтобы выйти туда надо справиться с собой
нужно порядок привести с собой а потом
уже уходить туда тогда ты почувствуешь
ту информацию которую ты должен написать
стихотворение мелодия тренд музыки
звучание и после этого ты уже точно
понимаешь что каждый человек который
услышав если конечно услышать сейчас
очень сложно попадать если человек
услышать что-то цепляет в этом тексте в
этой музыке секрет музыки именно только
в этом и это не только мои мысли это
очень давно существующие музыкальном
рынке структуры
вот
второй момент внимание когда мы
захватываем именно когда вы уже все мы
тронули очень важнейшую Аспект человека
характере личности или же выбора уже да
И тут самый страшный Ну сложное Эти люди
реально начинают тебя уважать потом
реально дальше что-то спрашивать у тебя
и ты грубо говоря захватывая внимание Ты
должен помочь расти себе и их тоже это
непрерывный процесс
улучшения и вот тут очень многие звезды
как-то вот так уходит там Наверняка вы
знаете
вот объяснение понимание Почему люди
грубо говоря с ума сходит музыканты
Большие звезды тогда уходит какие-то там
моменты Не выдерживаетесь потому что
ты грубо говоря полностью оставляешь
собственную Я здесь Нужен контроль и вот
туда вовремя надо уходить или я не знаю
это уже сами кризис и блогерам
инфляйтерами чувств Я думаю то есть это
у всех на самом деле очень интересная
мысль кстати
происходит из-за того что мы становимся
заложниками только своей профессии Вот
Мы обязаны делать только контент
какой-то по работе потому что я
журналист на самом деле когда ты
разъединишься почему топовые блогеры
сегодня супер популярные потому что они
не заложники своей профессии они
заложники Просто даже не заложники они
транслируют свою жизнь настоящую То есть
у них весь контент подходит отсюда
А многие предприниматели не вот все Я
эксперт Я предприниматель я должен быть
только таким И вот они контент публикуют
только такой который связан с их
профессией но без профессии люди любят
вас даже артисты они любят то что он
живой настоящий искренне Да И вот когда
и когда человек убирает профессию я не
могу сказать там на второй момент Ну
просто старается разъединяться тогда
внимание становится еще больше потому
что контент уже стала суперблога а
Подписчик выбирает себе героя с которым
похож внутренние и зачастую выбирает по
моменту что этот герой меня будет
вдохновлять
сложностями и так далее вот мы видим
такую историю что чем чаще И чем быстрее
сегодня какой-то предприниматель Эксперт
начнет транслировать просто себя без
всех этих марок то он привлекает больше
внимания нежели когда прям готовится
что-то делать такое
очень важно потому что смотрите вы
говорите О себе Вот почему нужно сначала
подготовить себя Представьте сейчас
очень скажем дешевый такой же
качественный
для души наверное какие-то правильные
вещи она становится больше популярнее
чем какие-то правильные вещи согласен и
поэтому Сперва нужно понять фильтровать
насколько ты к этому готов и молодежь
делая определенные тренды не осознавая
что они Дальше сами будут делать И вот
почему я своим ученикам всегда говорю ты
готов ли к этому потом что ты делаешь
сам должен сперва написать еще какой-то
мысль ты дальше будешь потому что там
есть определенная ответственность к
этому и Вот почему я всегда в первую
очередь запрещаю о себе говорить потому
что если ты грань не поставишь Видимо
это это сейчас реально это больше
музыкальной сферы именно я наблюдаю
мы думаем что мы же сами Мы же самый
любимый для себя
мы там крутые думаю
А вот это не контролируем поэтому я
согласен
так так что ты согласен
тут на самом деле большой комплекс в
любом случае как бы ну для для нас
например главный ингредиент - это в
любом случае трушность естественно если
ты Ну э-э через экран в любом случае
заметно когда ты что-то делаешь аналитию
э заметка Да что-то делаешь фальшивые
это естественность и неестественное даже
есть комментарии верю Да
есть комментарии и верю потому что очень
много разного контента челленджей Там
многие делают и видно что где-то
подстаново где-то в одной эмоции не
настоящие и прям Люди уже созрели
аудитория они пишут верю не верю там то
есть
я не знал
юмористический сериал и в любом случае у
нас во главе Ну как бы подача информации
это естественность если у нас есть
персонаж он максимально должен быть
приближен жизни То есть это не должен
быть книжный литературный я не знаю по
лекалам 20 века литературы человек Нет
он не должен быть таким он должен быть
максимально близок к аудитории то есть
чем он Ближе к человеку зрителю тем
больше к нему внимание Как вы говорите
Симпатия и таким образом смотрите
Давайте немного подытожим первое нужно
отделять
личность от профессии и не давить только
на профессию но еще показывать себя как
личность а второй момент нужно четко
определиться с теми смыслами которые ты
будешь доносить аудитории третье это
трущность чтобы ты был реальный не
фальшивый реальный
[смех]
надо быть красивой
что она умная а умная говорит что она
красивая умная и красивая
На самом деле я вот говоря о своей
личной истории Я начинала действительно
просто делиться своими проектами
рассказывать о них то что я делаю как я
живу и моей жизни всегда был спорт
бизнес и обучение и многое другое и это
реально отвлекалось во многих девушек в
том числе потому что они боялись у
многих страх на самом деле начинать
страх везти в том числе социальные сети
бизнес многое другое и я поняла свою
миссию в социальных сетях потому что
иногда ты думаешь Для чего я это делаю
вопросом но я поняла что как минимум
вдохновлять давать классный пример и
просто давать понять что каждая девушка
в Казахстане Может начать проект своей и
это возможно и мне кажется тем самым тем
что я делилась своим опытом своей
историей Я выступала на 5 ток
рассказывала это очень такое знаете
персональную историю из меня прям
вытащили организаторы И говорили
Расскажи свою личную историю там как у
тебя не сложился брак или еще что-то
хотя Знаете мне казалось нашем обществе
это не принято делиться своими чувствами
засмеют как минимум это было до
какого-то времени вы только последние
несколько лет все Вот пошли за
трушностью потому что это такой мировой
тренд Вот и у нас вот история на самом
деле в социальных сетях кости это вообще
Сначала ты должен вроде как бы всем
сейчас все показывать потому что
социальные сети обнажают все Как ты
живешь Что ты ешь как ты на какой машине
ты ездишь это требует и например и в то
же время есть наша ментальность кости
лучше не показывает
тихо ходить и ничего нет то есть это
постоянно такая некая грань
которая ты должен уметь работать
Вы можете люди должны зрители ваши
вашего подкаста должны помнить Мне
кажется что я почувствую и за время вот
хайпов и не только заметила люди тебя
могут превознести очень высоко и также
быстро тебя уронить и поэтому здесь Мне
кажется нужно для себя понять это Что
говорит нужно быть в этом году То есть
не надо не нужно строить иллюзии по
поводу своей аудитории нужно четко
понимать за что ты несешь ответить что
ты транслируешь и что они тебе могут
дать потому что социальная сеть это в
первую очередь обратную связь Это что
марган клеила столько много подписчиков
я заметила что именно молодежь вас очень
любит Казахстана Почему Потому что это
гибкий ум это интересующиеся люди Они
очень сильно хорошо откликаются на идее
ваши и поэтому опять же нужно помнить
что со всеми нужно максимально аккуратно
но в то же время небес манипуляций
хороших тоже они
есть манипуляции в лучшем то есть плохие
манипуляции На мой взгляд и хорошие
когда ты хочешь повлиять на внимание
не согласен
важные вещи говорить и начинаете то есть
важно получается
Ещё скажи я мужчина
сказал что ты старшая нас ты можешь
сказать что это был комплимент
я знаете называю манипуляции в том числе
хорошими когда ты хочешь действительно
повлиять на людей чтобы они изменились
своё мнение по отношению к чему-то
другой вопрос что нет я говорю вы
смотрите вы говорите очень важные вещи
манипуляция вряд ли в первую очередь я
себе задаю я готов влиять людям кто я
такой чтобы
в первую очередь нужно ли вообще
смотрите есть мои мысли есть чужие мысли
так вот если мои мысли становятся
триггером для чужих людей где его
личность Почему человек перестал мыслить
выбор каждого следить за вами смотрите
опять же теперь выбор мы поставили очень
важным выбор выбор это в том числе
Великий выбор Это самый Великолепная
вещь что человек у меня четверо детей я
говорю Выбирай сам никогда не делай так
чтобы кто-то тебя повлиял посмотри
оттуда отсюда будет свободен и вот когда
мы говорим только что поделились вам
личную информацию что я осталась
Представьте что одна девушка маленькая
Вы же не знаете во что это может
превратиться поэтому наш ролл модуль это
не есть стопроцентный успех
потому что вы же не можете
контролировать
Не ну по вашей логике Ерболат При всем
уважении к вашим творчеству Да спасибо
нет сомнения я просто не про это я про
то что по вашей логике нужно тогда
сидеть идея ничего не делать не влиять
Нет но я просто грубо говорящий конечно
утрирую по вашей логике нужно Ну не знаю
если мы говорим за концепцию религии
даже пророк мухаммадвёл людей за собой и
влиял поэтому здесь вопрос такой Каждый
выбирает то что во что он верит
идеологию и он несёт сам ответственность
и винить условно кумира своего кумиров
нельзя возводить Но если винить кого-то
в своих неуспех это инфантильно
инфантильно и в наше общество К
сожалению в большей степени инфантильная
и здесь я говорю когда ты видишь что
человеку надо помочь ты хочешь протянуть
ему руку часть подписчикам а там дальше
ответственность начинается
самое интересное Знаете в чем
заключается в том что
э у нас по сути и выбора нет смотри
Вопрос такой что либо ты влияешь на
людей либо кто-то другой либо ты
употребляешь вопрос в том что не бывает
те люди которые сидят на той стороне Да
люди на них по-любому кто-то влияет То
есть ты не можешь сказать Так я перестаю
на вас влиять чтобы на вас никто не
влиял Проблема в том что пустоты не
бывает обязательно будет кто-то другой
влиять и вот этот кто-то другой может
оказаться в 10 раз хуже тебя и
соответственно он может влиять Так что
он захватит внимание и наши дети будут
слушать его а потом у тебя будет
конфликт со своими детьми потому что он
что-то там уши свое влил просто еще
такой момент
человек который влияет он транслирует
определенные мысли но не факт человек в
любом случае продукт определенной
информации возможно его парадигма в
которой он верит возможно тоже ошибочно
здесь в любом случае это зависит от
принимающей стороны от потребителя То
есть у него всегда есть Вы должны быть
какие-то я не знаю принцип или фильтры
восприятия или отторжение
мне кажется должно быть больше практики
публичных изменений например вот если
блогер ошибся или что-то сказал или там
повел не так свою аудиторию Нужно
обязательно извиниться как это делать в
Японии в Китае и в Корее Я считаю я
очень люблю юго-восточной Азии Поэтому я
считаю что нужно именно так то есть
ошибился ничего страшного надо
признаться трудно признать свои ошибки и
твоя аудитория должна видеть что я
ошибся Ребят вы могли тоже Поэтому
пожалуйста
а вот это кстати эго здесь надо
переступить принять что ты живой человек
и надо как-то
Потому что
тезисе сказали что как аудитория можете
возвысить также втоптать землю
коммуникации здесь надо учиться им прям
день-ночь видеть что если ты ошибся надо
вперед аудитории опередить их и самому
признаться в том что ты ошибся и это
если ошибка Она
повторяется часто одна и та же тогда
аудитории
на самом деле здесь
смотрите еще важно понимать такую вещь
что мы все даем различные альтернативы
нашим подписчикам или потребителям я еще
к тому что мы должны быть как
супермаркет
20 видов зубной пасты 20 видов блогеров
один признается в своих ошибках
совершает ошибки косячит постоянно
плачет изменяется
какой дурак
Помогите мне исправиться Напишите в
комментах что я должен и он любимчик для
определенного категории людей понимаешь
потому что таких людей очень много а
другой человек сидит Он сильный он
говорит что эти сопли жуёт постоянно вот
мне нравится другой блогер который
делает ошибки Ну не показывает виду и
продолжаем
Вот это мужик конкретно вот мне он
нравится и мы как блогеры как люди
которые влияют или имеют какой-то
кусочек внимания мы должны давать им
выбор выбор искать Вот ты хочешь Твоя
картина мира такая вот пожалуйста вот
такое поведение есть картина мира такая
вот такое и таким образом Вот ты несешь
ответственность в плане того что ты свою
полку тоже должен выставить и сказать
вот выходить такой стиль такой образ
жизни Вот я не факт что влияю Вы сами
выбираете того кто будет на вас влиять
добавила вот по поводу супермаркета
просто на самом деле сейчас если раньше
казалось что условно РБК или какие-то
другие BBC меди смотрят определенную
аудиторию это не так в одной семье
контент потребляет семья Ну по-разному
кто-то читает там Facebook кто-то в
телеграме то ли Инстаграме и они тем не
менее остаются семьей Здесь вопрос такой
просто у каждого свое мнение и каждая
выбирает то что ему нравится поэтому
здесь Согласно с вами Мне кажется еще
знаете количество превращается в
качество когда у тебя много-много разных
блогеров кто-то будет отпадать потому
что аудитория не будет принимать и все
равно воронка сужается здесь вот ваши
переживания по поводу действительно
ваши они имеют место быть потому что я
тоже переживаю когда я вижу что девочкам
транслирует неправильные вещи продают
странные курсы инфокусы или там мужчины
там продают кто тебе показал как будто
хорошие
Нет я просто к тому что когда я это вижу
мое сердце тоже болит но здесь вопрос
вот как Мурка отметил тоже Либо мы либо
другие рынок еще и зриедже в том числе
онлайн не хочет себе уже смотреть Тот
контент который ему не нравится даже
взять Telegram в телеграме появились
сторисы Да функция но так как оказалось
что их могут смотреть все И ты смотришь
непонятно каких людей то есть я там
увидел Ринат арбуз я не подписан на него
но просто у меня был в контакта я не
хочу его наблюдать и в итоге то есть
люди не так активно пользуются сегодня
тем контентом который мне нравится и то
есть Telegram Stories но они пока просто
есть Он даже в отца Я очень многих на
многих подписан там контакты я не хочу
их смотреть А в Инстаграме или в других
площадках Ты же себе фильтруешь кто тебе
интересен
здесь на самом деле еще такой момент
мы хоть и боремся с кем-то там деше мы
видим по курсами и так далее так далее
вопрос Вот чем они тоже должны быть
потому что иначе как создаться иммунитет
согласен для того чтобы появился
Иммунитет это люди должны столкнуться и
понять что такое дешевое что такое
некачественное что такое грязное и так
далее поэтому это вот вечная борьба это
хаос и порядка доброго и светлого и так
далее это вечная борьба и бессмысленно
пытаться из интернета Выкинуть все
только грязное на самом деле оно будет
всегда там присутствовать и так далее у
людей это общество само будет созревать
и будет выкидывать на обочину то что ему
не нужно
[музыка]
на самом деле маргович очень классная
Франция сказала если не мы тут кто-то
другой в принципе я за то чтобы Ну мы же
говорим о внимании то есть ну то есть
тут тоже есть определенная софт миссия У
нас у всех нам важно создавать много
контента и хорошего И плохого в конце
концов Но самое конечное ну как бы
задача чтобы Казахстан он жил именно
казахстанском информационном
пространстве большинстве нам важно чтобы
внимание нашего населения оно было
приковано к каким-то нашим внутренним
вещам нашим внутренним ценности потому
что где-то определённо до пятнадцатого
года если вы Обратите внимание где-то
60-70%. Ну я может быть не знаю точно но
большинство людей оно как бы телом здесь
Но внимание которое является самым оно
было мозгами вниманием они где-то в
российском пространстве
очень как бы опасно в плане того что это
все отвлекается через десятилетия сейчас
Если вы Обратите внимание Да и нам
сейчас важно всем как бы создавать
контент именно для Казахстанского чтобы
у нас было Вот ребята сделали огромную
работу музыканта это очень круто то есть
казахский язык возвели вообще на новый
уровень кино сериалы ты вышел То есть у
нас есть свои мемы мы сейчас даже КВН
или какой-то площадка мы Не шутим как
раньше про Пугачёву или Филиппа
Киркорова У нас есть свои персонажи
адаптивные
в плане Мы работали десятилетиями на это
чтобы сформировать свое пространство
информационное этого еще мало Нам
необходимо расширять чтобы жить какой бы
он национальности не был и казах и
русских и украинец чтобы они жили в
нашем информационном а вот еще я верну
вас к вниманию И к тому как захватывать
внимание да Как вы смотрите на то что
вот
есть разные примеры когда люди
захватывали внимание на чем угодно на
Кремля не на различных пранках нам Ким
Кардашьян на своей заднице и так далее а
потом сначала захватывали внимание а
потом начали давать контент потому что
во-первых они начали монтировать через
рекламу потом у них появились деньги
благодаря деньгам они начали привлекать
экспертов благодаря экспертам они у них
начал контент выправляться стать жирнее
хорошими и так далее И постепенно они
превратились нормальных
контент-продюсеров начинали они с того
что кривлялись и показывали задницу
и вот как вот молодые блогеры задают
вопрос например как стать популярным вот
если давать Я заметил сам когда я
начинал социальной сети я смотрел есть
два лагеря первый лагерь это хайпожоры
которые все время ловит что бы то не
происходило и задача поймать
и у них много подписчиков и вторая
второй лагерь это люди которые пишут
серьезный контент но у них нет
подписчиков Ну или мало подписчиков и
вот как вот сделать так вот Давайте
совет дадим людям которые хотят
раскачать свой личный бренд
как-то захватить внимание как
действовать сразу писать серьезные вещи
или ловить хайп здесь Наверное как мы
уже с рынка entertainmenta развлечений
вот что такое развлечение мы сами
Говорите Нужно развлекая правильная
информация просто объединить вопрос
Когда мы допустим опять же ничего вы
если прислушайтесь к тексту там очень
сложные тексты Ну когда мы об этом
тексте мы что-то пытаемся тогда клип
снять или же биться создать Мы же не
говорим
мы делаем в тренде очень современный
яркой даже это быстро битый специально
балансировать
да вот и все поэтому необходимо никогда
не оставлять про интертеймент Да но
здесь подразумевается смотреть когда мы
идут а именно то мы подразумеваем
образование
шины райдос шикарные шины Я же
комплект
[смех]
так вот смотри когда мы элемент то
подразумевается
развлекаловку мы используем как крючок
Да и должны дать образование это
образование это значит смыслы вот
молодой человек хочет стать популярным у
него в голове еще нету смысла Ну я про
свой кейс расскажу что он хочет чему
хочет научить То есть у нас был у нас
до социальных сетей у нас основная школа
КВН в любом случае там есть
преемственность поколений там прививают
какие-то ценности это это не стоит есть
какие-то темы на которые не стоит
которые могут там не знаю обидится
поэтому
определенная школа у нас была но когда
мы появились на телевидении в любом
случае
первое что мы сделали Мы хотели сделать
то что нету на нашем пространстве мы
начали с пранков 2008 год на телевидении
на казахском языке
да то есть мы привлекли внимание
уже в этих пранков мы начали пранках мы
начали вставлять какие-то смысл это
ценности семейные то есть там мост
пошлости не было наоборот мы хотели
показывать какие-то естественно
человеческие эмоции
Семейные ценности даже будут беркутся и
шеи сидят они как-то строили пранк чтобы
они выражали друг другу какие-то
позитивные смыслы позитивные эмоции
затем уже в самой передаче у нас
разговор нашел на казахском языке
юмористического плана то есть там тоже
нет возможности поэтому где-то сквозь
смех Мы тоже какие-то смыслы вставляем
транслируем какие-то поэтому важно
захватить внимание
обратить на себя внимание удержать
внимание и все-таки развлекает
так и напрашивается монетизировать А вот
момент чтобы стать популярным однозначно
нужно себе привлечь внимание потому что
контент сейчас стало но очень много вот
прям чересчур много осталось стать супер
популярным сложно мы начали копаться что
нужно сегодня обычному человеку чтобы он
о себе заявил Да вот как-то громко в
целом чтобы люди его узнали на него
подписались А Или ты затрагиваешь
какой-то инфоповод который сегодня люди
обсуждают второе или ты сам создаешь
этот повод То есть ты можешь быть сам
создателем того же инфоповода грубо
говоря я сажусь на диету пять дней буду
без сахара это же инфоповод людям
интересно посмотреть этот сериал позиция
а достигнешь ты это или не достигнешь
Это потому что Да То есть у человека
есть представление Я каждый день захожу
в социальные сети и каждый день там
какой-то не идет контент я должен вот на
вас подписаться увидеть то что вы себе
заявили такую интересную цель и мне
становится дикой интересно Сможете ли вы
в течение там 5 дней продержаться и
какой у вас будет момент Вот здесь мы
для себя сделали
сегодня популярным ты можешь делать
контент идти в долгую ты можешь сегодня
делать инфоповоды сам это вызовы себе
бросать это еще интереснее с точки
зрения ты сам развиваешься ты сам
показываешь настоящие эмоции второе это
момент ты делаешь какие-то популярные
челленджи вот Искусство это зачастую
плагиат нельзя сегодня Многие думают что
я должен что-то гениальное придумать а
Гениально уже есть просто бери повторяй
и делай пример на своем примере
показываю Мы решили супругой повторить
Челлендж Я беременный с арбузом он
набрал очень много просмотров он набрал
там два с половиной миллиона просмотров
тик токи тоже я сам бы не придумал Это
ни с того ни с чего придумать этот я
просто посмотрел я увидел что там была
реакция интересно я решил повторить и то
есть зачастую я стараюсь видеть то что
иногда просто Повторите теперь такой
вопрос
я я да Ну если хочешь чтобы твой
прогремел и говорит Все подожди кто-то
так делал уже да или там в своё время
сожгли храм артемиды эфесской тоже ну
как бы чтобы оставить в истории так что
инфоповоды они как бы ещё с древних
времен
другой вопрос Вот получается смотри
человек есть способ стать популярным
через контент он долгий сложный
второе - это через это то что сейчас
прям вот популярно вот хороший лайфхак
записывайте вопрос
говорить
с арбузом очень огромное количество
просмотров набрало значит ли что вы
стали популярным
Хороший вопрос здесь я смотрю на
показатель подписчиков
То есть если они добавляются значит люди
хотят дальнейшем смотреть твой контент А
если они просто посмотрели его в позиции
испытали какую-то эмоцию там да Круто
или не очень даже это хорошо то есть
момент того что ты становишься
популярным надо рассмотреть в Лонг долго
то есть ты себя здесь показал ты себя
здесь показал раньше достаточно было там
два три касания сделать чтобы стать
популярным сейчас нужно касание 40 я
сегодня вас здесь увидел на подкасте
увидел еще где-то я уже в голове думаю а
этот человек интересный он делает
контент он выступает где-то А давай-ка
на него подпишусь люди стали жадными на
подписку вообще жадными то есть они
подписываются на тех кто становится кто
уже популярны А те кто не популярны они
себе задают вопрос А зачем еще я буду
подписываться на кого-то и вот такая
интересный момент то что те кто
популярны они будут становиться еще
популярнее те кто Просто употребляет
контент они будут и употреблять контент
и вот есть даже интересное высказывание
что налог для бедных будет реклама
то есть вот я не говорю бедный это не
означает там в каком-то социальном
моменте А это означает момент что у тебя
мало подписчиков и ты будешь всегда
употреблять контент Когда происходит
сатурация рынка любого рынка рация это
кристаллизация рынка происходит
разделение и происходит экономика
блокбастеров и это в супермаркетах тоже
смотрите такую вещь происходит раньше
была там одна две три зубной пасты и мы
приходили выбирали и потом начали
количество зубных страстей Расти расти
их уже заходишь 30 штук и ты уже не
паришься ты берешь либо блендами все и
получилось экономика блокбастеров когда
один процент зубных паст берет 90
процентов выручки а остальные 99 берут
там 10 процентов выручки то же самое в
блокбастерах один блокбастер снимает
кассу всех остальных фильмов года и
в блогерстве то же самое сейчас
происходит сейчас происходит так блогеры
становятся так много что люди уже не
хотят париться не хотят париться в
результате крупные становятся еще
крупнее а мелким пробиться крайне тяжело
и вот кстати я думаю очень полезная
лайфхак будет как я сам лично трактую
реакции на что я смотрю я смотрю Первое
это на шеринг то есть поделиться сколько
под моим постом Люди делятся насколько
хорошо делись Дело в том что смотрите
психология как когда ты прочитал
какой-то пост если он тебе полезен и ты
знаешь что он полезен будет всем твоим
друзьям знакомым ты его начинаешь
отправлять потому что в каждом человеке
хочется делиться хорошим
ты начинаешь отправлять наши шире
показывает что пост очень хороший это
самое главное качество поста дальше если
человек считает что другим навряд ли
будет полезно или сомневается но он
знает что точно ему точно полезен то Он
сохраняет
то есть для себя Он сохраняет потому что
ему полезен Но для других он сомневается
будет полезно или жадничать
дальше если он
то что ты написал идеально в него
ложится Либо наоборот он страшно против
того что ты написал он пишет коммент в
комменте либо хейтеры либо фанаты
середнячков мало либо хейтер либо фанаты
почему потому что чтобы написать Контент
это коммент это же энергию надо
потратить А чтобы потратить А у тебя
должен быть импульс эмоциональный
импульс блин Что за херню он пишет Что
за глупость ты пишешь
капец как классно огонь
так пишут либо хейтеры либо
а дальше есть такое лайк лайк это когда
в принципе нормально в рамках твоих
ожиданий он такой окей Все в рамках
твоих ожиданий и вот это очень важно
уметь интерпретировать вот эти все вещи
можно я вот проговорю наверное зрителям
Я бы наверное не хотела чтобы все
стрессовали по поводу того чтобы стать
популярными там и гнаться за этим
могу как бы свое мнение вот смотрите
есть понятие драйва и кайва кайфа
Дофамин и серотонины то что гормоны
которые делают нас счастливыми или
подталкивает на то чтобы нужно что-то
сделать невероятное так вот это все
должно быть в балансе согласись же что
блогер Никита постоянный драйв для
кого-то это абсолютный кайф Она
просыпается блогерша или блоге день ночь
делится своей жизни ему это приносит
удовольствие Для вас например может быть
стресс Я не хочу делиться поэтому здесь
момент такое что не нужно идти против
своей воли нужно просто Кайфовать от
того что ты либо делаешь или не делаешь
Я бы еще хотела сказать по поводу кстати
показатели
лайфхак такой мне кажется как только
открывается новая новая социальная сеть
и вы хотите быть популярными Старайтесь
быть первыми там свое время tiktok очень
сильно драил креаторов они где-то мне
кажется даже закручивали какие-то
показатели чтобы ты у тебя было желание
тебя подпитывали цифрами что ты больше
создавал больше и поэтому если вам прям
дико хочется то Инстаграм это уже такой
как вот
поесть инноваторы которые быстро успели
залезть в этот поезд есть это люди
которые уже поздно реагируют и конечно
тогда сложнее прийти Там стать
популярным Инстаграме Там не только
поэтому есть стресс есть новые
социальные сети которые превратилась из
твиттера в X поэтому здесь ваш выбор
хотите быть популярными идите сюда где
есть новая аудитория есть другая подача
возможно ваша и вы бы это будет сильно
резонировать с вашими ценностями Вот но
в целом Я считаю так вот мне не нравится
эта погоня за вот этими лайками и вот
борьба за внимание потому что знаете
внимание нужно как вы говорили
танцульками постоянно привлекать и можно
из этого в образ и образа никогда не
вылезти никогда и застрять ним мы
Сколько примеров Вы видели такое Ну и
звёзды в том числе А можно конечно
превратиться как мы говорили с
количеством качества поэтому Ребята вы
не стрессуете на самом деле
Нужно ли быть популярным то есть
самоцель в целом
сегодня Да мне кажется важно быть
например в нашей сфере
популярность это мерила задача
То есть мне кажется не обязательно
каждому человеку становится популярным
на большую массу каждому да если ты уже
вот в этой истории в плане того что ты
руководитель или ты сегодня хочешь
какой-то не знаю уровень новых клиентов
Ты должен уже быть соцсетях То есть это
уже работа по допустим ты Придя твоя
работа
такой интересной ситуации зачастую
сегодня вот сотрудники это мериньял да
Вот куда куда они идут работать они идут
те компании Где есть интересное движение
какое-то корпоративная культуры и так
далее А кто это будет транслировать на
аккаунт рабочий никто не подписывается
давайте объективно то есть людям
наплевать на какие-то просто аккаунты
рабочие уже это прям подтвержденный факт
людям интересно подписаться на
руководителя того же самого
предпринимателя который активно
транслирует интересную жизнь транслирует
то кем сотрудник Может у него стать И
для него и для сотрудника ты являешься
некой ролевой моделью то есть не быть в
соцсетях нельзя Вот давайте объективно
Ладно если проговаривать про Европу люди
там не так сильно пользуются соцсетями
да
сегодня ты ищешь себе психолога ты куда
захочешь ты в Инстаграм или по сарафанке
прашешь скинь его аккаунт посмотреть там
давать как он выглядит ты знакомишься
сегодня с человеком парень с девушкой ты
все посты проверяешь все какое хорошее
не маньяк там ну и так далее вот здесь
основной момент что соцсети в соц сетях
должны все быть однозначно но фактор
такой Все ли должны быть популярной Нет
все уже от цели здесь вопрос такой
смотрите с точки зрения опять трактовки
популярности Дело в том что
бытовом понимании мы понимаем
популярность это когда Широкая
известность а на самом деле популярно Ты
может быть не широкой известности
например ты настройщик компьютеров там
не знаю чего-то там звуковых плат
компьютеров и все Ты в этом слою ты
должен быть популярный именно в своей
профессиональной среде если ты
специалист принципе но в своей
профессиональной среде Ты должен быть
популярный Вот это очень важно иначе ты
останешься без клиента значит и Просто
останешься без вопрос о том что то есть
Нужна ли я говорил о широкой
популярности то есть надо быть
специалистом если ты специалист То есть
у тебя
налаженной связи Это собственно есть же
популярность не обязательно в Инстаграме
находиться чтобы быть популярным
достаточно достаточно быть
в телефонной книжке то есть до этого
момента
есть одна проблема когда ты известен
среде профессионалов в их телефонной
книжке
они сидят в социальных сетях и в
какой-то момент там появляется такой же
специалист А ты не единственный В этом
мире который показывает свою жизнь и
показывает как он любит свое дело и эти
хотят Люди уже получать услугу не просто
специалиста а от крутого специалиста то
есть потому что это уже бренд Да потому
что это уже бренд Я хочу купить сапожки
не просто качественные сапожки а
качественные сапожки произведенные
известным знаменитым мастером Понимаешь
чем делать то есть важно быть популярным
социальных сетях для определенной
аудитории
чтобы продвигать свои скиллы способности
Я считаю даже 1000 подписчиков даже 500
подписчиков
То есть это большое количество людей
даже если у тебя уже 200 подписчиков ты
уже имеешь влияние
я на тебя подписаны интересные личности
А у кого больше И то есть ты можешь уже
влиять Но это кстати какой-то такой
социальное давление когда ты например
транслируешь у тебя уже есть пять тысяч
человек ты условно ты что-то заявил все
равно это должен сделать потому что ты
это заявил и ты уже не то чтобы мы не
даже ответственность А про такой некий
драйв Челлендж что ты должен это сделать
то что люди ожидают этого мне кажется
каждый казах рождается с пятистами
подписчиками
[смех]
просто популярность ты хорошо заметил
[музыка]
Ты популярным здесь разделить две вещи
важно Первое это популярность а второе
Доверие уровень доверия подписчиков тебе
потому что для тех кто хочет в будущем
монетизировать свою популярность или
зарабатывать деньги в социальных сетях
так вот очень важно не просто количество
подписчиков от того насколько они тебе
доверяют потому что если они не доверяют
они ничего не покупают Даже если ты
призываешь даже есть термин такой Call
To Action когда ты призываешь
подписчиков что-то сделать если они тебе
не доверяют они ничего не делают это
зачастую кстати происходит у артистов у
них очень много подписчиков но из-за
того что они там косячат там попадают
куда-то в Переделки и так далее людям
интересно за ними наблюдать подписчиков
много но они не доверяют
[музыка]
Что нужно делать для того чтобы люди
доверяли вам подписчики доверяли
Я думаю чтобы твоя страница была
максимально как мы говорили дружной но
здесь вопрос такой например
если ты эксперт то ты должен быть хорош
Понятное дело что ты не можешь сразу
заявить о себе что я лучше и так далее
ты был должен расти и мне кажется я в
моем случае смотрите как со мной
работает Если А я говорю я делаю для
меня это очень важно поэтому люди знают
что если заурия сказала пообещала она
обязательно это сделает И для меня это
такая моя личная ответственность перед
своим подписчикам и друзьями не только
далее я не показываю того что я считаю
не нужным Ну условно то есть моя жизнь
не вся наизнанку Хотя мне кажется мне
было больше подписчиков
Вот потому что я считаю что моей
аудитории неинтересный
некоторые вещи то что интересно кому-то
я себя где-то лимитирую ограничиваю
Потому что четко понимаю что я хочу
транслировать и они уже знают у них есть
понимание что если они заведут на
страницу то они узнают что есть какие-то
классные Гранты для предпринимателей они
узнают что знают про какие-то программы
для девушек многое другое То есть я
думаю что вот какое-то должно быть
соответствие своей Личностью на своей
странице кто-то кем ты являешься и что
ты рассказываешь потому что вы ведь Как
говорится неправду сейчас стало намного
быстрее чем когда-либо И что Конечно
является плюсом
а я получается трушность то есть
естественно правдивость а второе
выполнять свои обязательства и третий
экспертность вот эти три вещи которые
вызывают в людях Доверие Что еще можно
Да я думаю смотрите
[музыка]
тебя начнут тебе начнут доверять и
верить твоей правде твоим каким-то
поражением победам в случае если люди
будут понимать Зачем ты это делаешь то
есть важно проговорить свою мечту Вот
что ты делаешь И когда ты проговорил
свою мечту для своим подписчикам то есть
вот мне нравится вот это потому что я
хочу сделать что-то большое масштабное И
когда в этом поле ты начинаешь делиться
своими какими-то поражениями то что у
нас не получилось наш концерт отменили и
так далее но мечта же большая и люди
начинают говорить блин Вот я вижу как
этот человек старается Я начинаю ему
верить потому что я вижу глобальную
Зачем А когда Эксперт сегодня без
глобального Зачем что-то диктует ни с
того ни с чего выходит там допустим
информация Как правильно кушать Откуда я
знаю как правильно нужно кушать я не
доверяю но если это Эксперт Я хочу чтобы
все казахстанцы у них у всех был хороший
желудок примерно говорю я буду в этом
делиться тем что я знаю Может я буду
говорить это банальные вещи Может если
говорить ерунду я буду учиться и то есть
я вот вижу что фильтр происходит такой
что человек Кому мы доверяем то есть мы
понимаем его глобальный цех зачем и уже
дальше мы доверяем больше больше больше
больше и мы видим его такую некую
цепочку получается я бы Мечтал
предсказуемость предсказуемость когда
люди знают
то они могут предсказать что он будет
делать что он не будет делать И это
вызывает Доверие в людях вызывает
предсказуемость вызывает двери потому
что каждый раз если мы знаем что мы
сделали человеку что-то а он Мы же
ожидаем что вот я ударил плечо Я ожидаю
или там Я тебе принес воду я ожидаю что
в ответ ты мне скажешь спасибо если ты
вместо этого ты берешь стакан воды
брызгаешь лицо мы все думаем что ты
неадекватно
[смех]
это ощущение будет Ну те люди не любят
неадекватных людей потому что они
непредсказуемы боятся и боятся любых
непредсказуемых людей бояться событий
непредсказуемых и так далее но они
безумно интересны мы любим жить в
состоянии контроля поэтому когда человек
объявляет большой цели все его действия
предсказуемы и Люди доверяют потому что
знают что он делает А он делает это
потому что у него такая же цель Теперь
понятно он предсказуем он это делает
потому что да Он ошибся но он это ошибся
потому что предсказуемо пример илон Маск
все знают что он хочет хочет чтобы все
летали в космос и у него Ну не
получается что ракеты летают они падают
новости выходят здесь у него история но
люди же ему дальше продолжают верить
Потому что если это глобальная мечта Я
тот кто хочет чтобы мы научились летать
в космос
Я думаю еще последовательность Какая
некая должна быть она последовательность
сама по себе
последовательность нужна для того чтобы
людям показать что ты предсказуем да и
контролируешь
способ деятельности для убеждения людей
что ты действуешь так как они ожидали в
рамках неких самоирония Как вы думаете
Это же тоже момент доверия сильный когда
ты можешь
мощный инструмент это на самом деле
показывает что ты улетишь
на земле и ты осознаешь свое место и
поэтому людей это вызывает Доверие
Каждый раз когда люди знают что ты
реалист люди доверяют реалистам больше
безответственным оптимистом самоирония
она очень сильно работает
тип смешные моменты
и у меня рубрика есть
беру свои фейлы и у меня их очень много
которые за кадром и просто выкладывать
это набирает самый огромный когда грубо
говоря кто-то открылся ты руку держишь
Ну то есть он наоборот
Ну то есть вот такие вот какие-то
жизненные вещи и когда ты сам это
транслируешь
классные эмоции во-вторых подтверждают
что человек
и ты не настолько чтобы
которые откликается когда кому-то тоже
плохо на самом деле Потому Почему вот
ток-шоу помните были Пусть говорят и в
Америке такие шоу где все плачут дерутся
Это потому что они понимают что у меня
тоже такая жизнь Я посмотрю в моменте я
отвлекусь но у меня такая же жизнь никто
не едят
политтехнологов есть такой инструмент
американских Они специально делают
изъяны у кандидатов обязательно либо
падает на сцене либо ручку роняет либо
ручка протекает у него здесь просто
Либо что-то опрокидывает на себя и так
далее Это резко повышает уровень доверия
кандидатов
еще какие инструменты вызывает
это классная сказал бы наверное контент
Попробуйте написать 10 очень важных
пунктов который вы хотите что-то делать
и не надо слишком обширно уходить Нужно
какую-то направление взять потому что ну
допустим вот инфобизнес Это она как бы
сторона Да и еще какую-то там
развлекающий там Тик Ток это тоже другая
сторона когда слишком много направлений
идет там разные вещи тренды то что
сейчас говоришь Да я не могу
позиционировать человека кто Кто она чем
она конкретно занимается Я просто это
немножко путает людей уже понимаете А
тут есть хорошо вот Чем быстрее вы
объясните будущим вашим подписчикам вы
чем вы будете заниматься какие у вас
взгляды и что вы хотите сделать
это на самом деле
пока ты не определились свою
уникальность то Доверие к тебе будет
слабо угу вот я вот о том если это как
раз подразумевает что ты транслируешь
какие твои ценности во что-то веришь
этой транслируешь вот например вот я не
совсем согласен с тем что надо повторять
э-э то есть мне кажется Ну я извиняюсь
конечно да да я не совсем согласен что
нужно повторять то есть кто-то снял
видео и в Челлендж это превратить Мне
кажется больше должна быть уникальность
Да у нас в любое Искусство это
постмодерна так скажем это повторение
или совершенствование чего-то другого
поэтому даже если вы повторяете мне
кажется нужно сделать это по-другому да
не узнаваемости в любом случае мы
черпаем идеи откуда-то и делаем Это уже
со своим
То есть если у тебя какой-то новый
контент у тебя больше шансов как бы
обрести больше повторяешь Ну как бы это
уже будет повторение Бывает такое Я
просто очень много вижу Вот такой
несправедливости то есть люди ну скажем
из музыкальной индустрии кто-то спел
песню Она не стрельнула а второй человек
его же песню взял спел он стрельнул он
популярный это же несправедливо то есть
но он повторил просто это очень
несправедливо поэтому здесь для автора
Ну как бы пропадает мотивация что-то
создавать У нас тоже такой период мы
придумываем какие-то номера какие-то
шутки а кто-то в другой передаче Это то
же самое делает и нормально делать
контент
Чистой воды скилл и на первых этапах же
сделать что-то уникальное от слов
нереально
Почему Потому что Человеку нужно сделать
что-то то чего не делал никогда ранее а
это вызывает сегодня стресс А когда
стресс Я сегодня не хочу это делать В
итоге я просто опять же наблюдатель я
вот за то что то есть ты должен Я просто
по своему пути сужу То есть я не совсем
поддерживаю то что Ну вот миг просто
что-то сделать и разорвать Я просто по
себе сужу что вы например с КВН начинали
с маленьких пор маленькая шутка реприза
побольше домашнее задание потом мы
начали писать короткие сюжеты потом
начали снимать сериалы потом начали
снимать большие сезоны там всякие
патруль сериал то есть мы к этому
приходим постепенно и в итоге у нас есть
бэкграунд мы уже понимаем как Что
работает и в итоге это само по себе
работает во-первых контент уникальный
во-вторых У нас есть какой-то
определенный опыт
поэтому наверное надо прежде чем как бы
заниматься может быть надо изучить Я не
знаю достаточно иногда взять
один контент второй соединить получится
совсем другой никогда не получится под
копирку человек другой подача другая
форма другая есть же другое понимание
что
Зачем тебе сегодня делать от своего
интеллекта когда это может никому и не
нужно
а в этом же и Кайф А я сейчас объясню
что делать если если это из тебя то есть
ты это переварил То есть ты получил
внешнюю информацию поглотил Из тебя
выходит ну как бы совсем другой продукт
в этом же другое говорю здесь я
проговариваю про то что зачастую то что
ты делаешь Хочешь из интеллекта своего
сделать И ты думаешь это зайдёт это
зайдёт это не заходит ты должен
посмотреть что сегодня рынок кушает вот
что сейчас рынку нужно и дать то что он
в чём нуждается А многие сегодня вот мы
сейчас с вами ведём такую хорошую
дискуссию провести провести контент
через себя однозначно нужно не под
копику с точки зрения нужно понимать что
сейчас вообще рынку интересно грубо
говоря Если вы сейчас посидим и таки А
давай я сейчас напишу какой-то
тему который не актуальна А зачем это
делать ты тратишь на это энергию честно
говори мне о том что то есть баланс не
актуально мы говорим о создании
уникального контента либо копирки
понимаешь я проговариваю Ну вот момент
тоже сейчас говорим про то как стать
популярным зачастую сегодня рынок
диктует свою уже правила которые есть а
можно можно я Извините мальчики
я вижу с одной стороны я согласен с этим
эксперта Эксперт хочет поделиться миром
своим творением с этой стороны говорит а
нужно нужно ли твое творение миру
условно Мне нравится
или создам такой фильм Я продам меньше
это опять же выбор мое личное мнение
сейчас учетом всего хаоса в мире все
идет вот таким определенно другим разным
группам То бишь вот есть допустим такая
как Дискорд это социальная сеть или нет
Вот И там есть подгруппы словно
киберспорт и еще что и Каждый находит то
что ему нравится это и есть нишивость
как таковая А вот допустим когда ты
хочешь создавать количественный такой
контент такой чтобы я вот чтобы меня
весь Казахстан посмотрел чтобы заури
размат стал популярным это была ты
говорит Зачем идти сложным путем
создавайте то что как бы будет
потребляться массой а здесь уже выбор
такой
например в любом случае
мы создаем сериал
как бы назрел да то есть это на эту тему
то есть но это уникальный продукт
то есть было бы глубоко неприятно если
мы создали какой-то сериал и Мой коллега
то же самое сделал
вас Подписчик вот с рубрикой Вот которую
говорили полтора нет подождите я сейчас
не пытаюсь спорить А я подписчица ваша я
решила повторить вам будет это как это
нормально когда превращается в
Челленджер нормального когда
контентмейкер человек это как бы твой
коллега это повторяет Это неправильно
это очень Можно
твой зритель он как бы он как бы снимает
дабы с твоими Пускай ну как бы
фрагментами это круто
но когда ты например
своими словами и другой человек тоже
самое
Я понял что мы творческие люди Поэтому
нам действительно моменты бывают
[музыка]
здесь у меня был до этого вопрос мы
сейчас говорим
кого кого
ничего не твоя для меня всегда важно да
они всегда говорят маркетолог ты
классический маркетолог Поздравляю тебя
классно
А я с ними спорю подожди ты хочешь от
меня сделать блогера иди потому что моя
профессия очень древняя профессия музыка
это там очень нужно готовиться вот то
что он свой путь
Давайте Так
мы духовные существа мы творение и
человек должен творить
и соответственно когда я слышу что давай
просто чувствую творение возьмем и будем
создавать создавать
и вот тут нам больно Подожди подожди вот
вопрос Да мы ничего абсолютно правильно
говорить
Ну надеюсь когда-нибудь вещество станет
большинством А вот и здесь момент такой
должна быть какая-то Синергия что-то
посередине Объясню почему вы знаете
самое мое любимое Моя семья собирает Арт
то есть мы собираем спокойную кофтом
картины допустим вот и проблема
художников Какая он ревнует свою работу
он считает что почему я должен а
продавать ему есть такое он недостойные
картины есть Это правильно или там А
почему за такую цену Тут приходит
арт-менеджер для этой говорить хотите
зарабатывать или вы будете все время
голодны здесь художник должен решить сам
какой у него путь он будет всегда бедным
но гордым его работа останутся у него
дома висеть либо все-таки картины
достанутся более-менее какому-то
ценителю который купит и будет это ее
вариант поэтому не надо
трактовка как она просто один из
примеров Я к тому что здесь здесь
художники но мы не голодны
Другой путь можно можно и творить и
зарабатывать
уже Вопрос аналитики то есть опять же
говорим мы создаем бажа басики сериалов
очень много вы просто так смотри вот это
вот сейчас будет отраженостях это сильно
залетит Потому что есть такая социальная
проблема есть такие триггеры поэтому
Давайте в эту сторону
вот когда вы смотрите когда вы создаёте
Марат Вы же ориентируетесь на то что
полететь не полетит
это не означает что мы берём
Да
здесь вопрос такой с другой стороны
смотрите уже ориентируйтесь на
общественное мнение и вы хотите чтобы
это полетело продавалось и так далее То
есть по сути Вы тоже занимаетесь
маркетингом
всю семью да да просто речь изначально
шла о том что вот взять скопировать
стать популярным То есть мне кажется не
совсем вот
Искусство это плагиат
блогерсы когда там
когда чувак с арбузом изображал
беременную женщину это никак не сделаешь
авторское право на это не
распространение соответственно Это идея
Идея про то что можно использовать идеи
креативные идеи а потому что это не
авторский контент
Я теперь говорю о чём то есть это не
авторский Контент это ну как бы идеи
направления жанры это нормально то есть
использовать но я имею в виду то есть
речь изначально шла Как стать популярным
поэтому я говорю лучше чем повторять
что-то попытаться либо видоизменить это
и сделать лучше чтобы это было не похоже
совсем другое либо создать уникальный
продукт абсолютно уникальный продукт не
бывает и в любом случае продукт того что
ты потребляешь то есть сознательно
бессознательно то что ты читал смотришь
в любом случае это у тебя отвлекается и
выливается во что-то совсем иное поэтому
мы сейчас раз говорим лайфхаках то есть
Я рекомендую создавать продукт который
не похож что-либо другое Таким образом
мы подталкиваем людей к творчеству
творчеству это наш путь
просто Тик Ток немного размыл этот
вопрос справедливости когда
подмена понятием то есть есть Челлендж
люди то есть обычный пользователь он
делает Челлендж повторяет Это для него
это прикольно он сделал повторил для
него это пока А есть такие люди которые
повторяют что-то и на этом какие-то
блага зарабатывать
грубо говоря человек может взять чужую
песню
с пятью записать круто и и сказать что
это я же не украл это же кавер То есть
это подмена понятий то есть благодаря
Ну это же он же он же видоизменил это
его он взял песню песню и полностью
[музыка]
но есть
исполнители профессиональные исполнители
которые просто где-то без спроса
[музыка]
какой-то момент мы из Узбекистана просто
как бы музыку классная музыка играет
потом
из Румынии
потом когда люди начинают говорить А что
ты украл Нет я не украл это
уникальный контент и действительно
качественный
то тогда возможно скопировать
понимаете и тогда обижаться обижаться
условно то что тебя то здесь уже вопрос
к тебе как креатору ты сделаешь один раз
тебе ну там нельзя ковры лучше это такая
знаете это знаете в неком роде такая
внутренняя конкуренция с самим собой
самим собой ты себя подстегиваешь всем
образом поэтому здесь вопрос такой
невозможно защитить артиста К сожалению
в наши дни я не говорю что это хорошо Я
говорю невозможно уже с учетом того что
социальные сети настолько быстро
транслируют насколько Люди быстро
подхватывают эти идеи сидеть и
рефлексировать и переживать сильно я бы
не советовала я не репрессирую то есть
если когда вот вопрос авторства
[смех]
делают песни это класс то есть когда
повторяют твой контент превращается это
популярно речь о том что
профессионал он не должен как бы
классно сказала вопрос уникальности Вот
я не представляю что кто-то может
скопировать Цоя или Земфиру или
джахалиба яркие личности самостоятельно
четко узнаваемые и Любой кто будет
копировать сразу по сравнению
просто тусклые будут
всё понятно
Давайте поговорим еще одно тему связано
с популярностью
[музыка]
Как вы относитесь
[смех]
Как ты вообще реагируешь на хейт вообще
ты считаешь что это это реально хейт
прям я ненавидит ты считаешь или это
просто да все что кто-то как-то
представлял что по-настоящему это все
было да это всё по-настоящему было
если вот так мягко сказать да сорт Да
так и было
вопрос в том что когда ты делаешь А вот
а я был готов к этому
потому что я же из народа 100 человек и
Понятно Если человек спрашиваешь как ты
думаешь
ты уже понимаешь как общество среагирует
и соответственно когда ты готовишь свой
собственную концепцию там да со всеми
идеологиями Почему она нужна потому что
я профессионал своего дела музыка Это
огромный как бы софтпала который по идее
должна как функционировать обществе
которое зеркало опять же социума опять
же если мы возьмем самую структуру
музыки рынок как музыку мы абсолютно не
конкурировали западными или азиатскими
музыками и соответственно Мы понимали
что мы теряем не то что сейчас на данный
момент будущее потеряем вообще Потому
что дети слушают все Западное
а нашей страда на данный момент
и ты должен был сделать такой скачок А
когда ты делаешь скачок
что общество не готово и поэтому
когда люди хейтеры я пацана нэнчевану
говорил что мы не должны через призму
там да какие-то смотреть ты уже сейчас
должен понимать потому что они просто
этого не пока не понимают если с такой
колокольню прийти
чем мы занимаемся
вот
музыка
соответственно ты делаешь определенный
выбор и как бы тебя не делали бы люди
больно Мы не реагировали на это дело
именно благодаря этому через полтора
года просто
ушу уже бывает хайп поднимается потом
погасает как маркетолог ты знаешь все не
вечно и мы должны были прожить конкретно
именно этот период
Мы тоже умеем и твоя рекомендация не
реагирует на Хит продолжать делать то
что делаешь вопрос Если вы действительно
понимаете чем вы занимаетесь
профессиональным собирайте заниматься
выбрали собственную профессию путь Вы
должны вперед на 10 лет или пять лет
хотя бы понимать что вы хотите сделать И
когда пойдет понятное дело у вас должен
быть четко допустим у вас среди сидят
коллеги пример может быть какой-то
религиозный человек вы должны грубо
говоря поговорить мой продукт не сделать
так чтобы творили как-то пострадала
Давай сейчас поговорим грубо говоря и
соответственно ты понимаешь и объясняешь
ему свой точкой зрения Почему она должна
быть и смотришь реальность
ты сейчас живешь здесь и сейчас твой
рынок твоя музыка твой молодежь все
уходит и вот вопрос только когда ты
сможешь логически Нормально ответь
получить у себя поговорить определенными
людьми какой-то там да дискуссию
устроить И после этого Когда будет
реагировать Вы должны ни в коем случае
это второй шаг уже внутренняя мотивация
ты сам только остаешься потому что все
будет хотеть даже вокруг тебя может
уйти потому что этот стресс очень многие
люди не смогут пережить и самым
последним человеком будете
и вот эта мотивация внутренней то что то
этого делали мотиватором вы сами должны
Если вы как капитан корабля Если вы
сейчас Садитесь все
напрасно нету смысла вообще И после
этого еще последствия будет дальнейшее
поколение
они не пойдут только что Маккей говорит
о том что
нынешние молодежные казахская контент
музыка очень сильно развита была
благодаря чему то что мы смогли
определенный путь
показать
Да вот хорошее слово поэтому важно опять
же там я не блогер и не Ваня не
собираюсь стать им Ну если вы решите
делать Нечто такое что не только вам
полезно
обществу полезно и будущему поколению
полезны Если вы сможете выбрать
собственный путь профессию самым главным
вы даже четко понимать именно
о важностях о выборах
Можно я
возвращаюсь
когда он сказал что девочку
Это моя ролевая модель Ведь я там не
призываю ни к чему плохого Я просто
рассказывал свой путь
там комментарии были очень
мое выступления я скажу Мне было 26 лет
мне было очень приятно я прям
разрыдалась
мой ребенок рядом который знала какой
путь у меня был она удивительно она
отказалась мудрее меня
вот сейчас на дворе 2023 год все что я
пережила тогда люди сейчас уже
переварили проработали С психологами и
многое другое и сейчас абсолютно другие
комментарии на том же видео оно стало
только сейчас настолько актуальным
потому что многие сталкиваются и как раз
таки девушки смотрят на это и думают она
переживает у нее получился человеком Я
хочу быть как она но в моменте я вам так
скажу я Очень чувствительный человек
Несмотря на то что я может быть в
Инстаграме не транслирую свою уязвимость
и так далее Я реагирую на каждый
комментарий пропускает через себя сейчас
стало блокировать просто потому что нет
времени разбираться потому что
доказывать что ты хорошая нет смысла вот
тогда мне пришлось вот знаете своей там
очень сильно много поработать на
удивление в моих социальных сетях У меня
нет хейтер то есть это были Рандомные
люди из России даже кто вообще не знает
кто я слеплена это было 5 выступления и
сейчас ко мне подходит девушки молодые
говорят Вы знаете я вас узнала вообще с
другой стороны я посмотрела этот топ и я
рыдала и знаете Если бы я боялась фейта
Ну в моменте я не ожидала что будет
такой эффект явно на свою душу наизнанку
не показывала и это было настолько не в
тренде рассказывать свою уязвимость
когда сейчас конечно я даже горжусь этим
выступлением вот а тогда я говорю я
рыдала всю ночь мой ребенок подошел меня
поддержал знаете кейту на самом деле в
моем случае я уже задумалась как мой
ребенок будет читать смотреть какой
пишет ее матери мне важнее ее мнение
нежели мне кого-то потом я сейчас просто
Блокирую Но это крайне редкость сто
процентов
людей которые может меня покритиковать Я
думаю вот здесь вопросы опять же
готовности
Я считаю что должны быть отдельно
психологи для социальных сетей которые
будут помогать тебе переживать этот
негатив это же тоже эмоция И здесь нужно
сразу не как страуса до головы и все
понять для себя определить негатив
относительно чего вас как личности или
вашего контента Что вы делаете вы даже в
вашем случае то есть я знаю какие вы
песни делаете они очень крутые А здесь я
смотрю на негатив с точки зрения людям
не понравилось допустим как тогда
выглядели ваши певцы то есть вот этот
образ да Но это же никак не означает что
именно к вам и вот когда ты уже делаешь
ранжирование А негатив к чему идёт и
зачастую он происходит К какому-то
контенту который ты в дальнейшем где-то
услышал или ты вот как Бунтарь
продолжаешь это делать И ты делаешь и
люди забывают или ты его меняешь от
рынка А если негатив касательно человека
ты вот совершил Ну какое-то неплохой
поступок то здесь я считаю не тяжело
извиниться и сказать да вот здесь у меня
была Вот такая ситуация я был не прав
можно здесь Раз уж мой контент
будущее скажем люди которые хотят
реально понимать что они делают
в любом случае если я даже этот
внешность не взял бы нас бы хотел
поверьте потому что там есть
определенная музыка жанра плюс там есть
определенные очень болезненный текст
поэтому чем я должен был в первую
очередь пожертвовать Лучше пусть
не саму Да волосами хейтят будет но зато
я про толкаю что самый важный продукт
музыку
и вот если вы останетесь специалисты вы
будете четко конкретно свой путь или же
свой выбор делать поэтому Будьте
специалисты
если мы говорим про популярность личный
бренд сегодня социальные сети и так
далее А есть много примеров мне
федорив Андрей маркетолог украинский он
рассказывал случаи как он со своим
другом поехали на Мальдивы отдыхать
семьей А друг только открыл ресторан
крутой ресторатор он открыл новый
ресторан какая-то новая пицца как-то
Поли робот
какая-то фишка
и он такой с чувством выполненного долга
запустил проект ресторан и поехал с нами
говорит отдыхать и тут произошло ужасное
кошмарное событие с точки зрения
маркетинга к ним в ресторан Пришел мужик
заказал пиццу съел пиццу потом сказал
что она ему не понравилась устроил
скандал за требовал возврат денег ему в
ресторан Если ты не понравился и надо бы
сразу отказаться отопиться съел и теперь
не понравилось
[смех]
но оказалось что он
инвалид
а ну инвалидность не такая что прям
видно
какие-то во-вторых он председатель
ветеранов войны
на Донбассе там Да
он потерял жену и воспитывает на руках
то ли одно то ли двух детей
отец-одиночка и говорит поднялся такой
Что на следующий день выступила жена
президента Зеленского и сказала В нашей
стране не место такого бизнеса Хотя
говорит ресторан сто процентов и
юридически по всем делам был прав вот
просто
пришел
не стал расплачиваться и что делать они
взяли его вытолкнули не били ничего но
факт то что так захотели ресторан Мой
друг у него чуть инфаркт не был на
Мальдивах Просто он быстро взял билет
поменял У него все насмарку отпуск
короче я его долго не видел встречаюсь
на снимке через год спрашиваю что как ты
пережил ресторан закрыл или нет он будет
не поверишь Это был лучший
прибыль столько как за 4 прошлых года
потому что
и все люди подумали Это что за пицца
такая что он съел и не рассчитался
это лучше коммерческий год его жизни
смотрите
существует такое понятие как любовь да
но любовь я считаю это жертвенность
Почему Потому что как Эрих From сказал
Любовь это глубокая заинтересованность в
развитии объекта любви то есть когда ты
кого-то или что-то любишь ты тратишь на
это свое время и энергию то есть по сути
ты тратишь свою жизнь то есть ты
жертвуешь жизнь ради объекта любви
и это любовь но с другой стороны если
взять другой полис любви это хейт Но
получается хейт это любовь просто с
другим знаком
внимание уделил в обоих случаях
уделяется внимание для того чтобы хейти
ты тоже трачу энергию и время
какой риторика в нашем обществе Когда
говорят плохой PR тоже PR и вот это
словосочетание дающее предложение оно
меня очень сильно
расстраивает потому что получается что
можно сделать что-то плохое и ты в любом
случае станешь популярным то что через
height На мой взгляд это неправильно
Потому что некоторые маркетологи
специально Надеюсь что это такое опять
же происходит манипуляция что все
обсуждают и Знаете есть уязвимые молодые
люди которые думают то есть они мозг еще
в гибкий они немножко уязвимые
восприятие информации и они думают если
вот хейт работает я буду это делать я
так как работаю в медиа
у нас в Казахстане выстроена по принципу
разбитых окон
[музыка]
Я тоже хочу то есть это такой
человеческий инстинкт и например Почему
наша Медиа настолько никак вообще
журналистиков Потому что когда ты
делишься хорошей новостью
никто не смотрит когда только ты что-то
пишешь сразу
700-1000 комментариев и так далее и вы
знаете вот семь лет теперь я по сей день
в дилемме то есть цифры хорошие это что
деньги правильно а с другой стороны ты
думаешь что такие цифры были тебе надо
писать только плохое и вот у нас миссия
такая свой проект
моя команда часто вот Находится в таком
состоянии когда они не понимают либо нам
надо хайповать либо нам надо выстраивать
свою линию некую философию там я не знаю
идеологию которая вот транслировала
нашему обществу Но с другой стороны как
будто бы на себя берем роль миссию самый
умные тут транслируем одно тоже
непонятно и поэтому я к тому что вот
когда
вот этот хейт ты просыпаешься днем
читаешь хейт кто кого убил кто с кем
встречается и так далее и так далее в
медиа в Казахстане выстроена именно так
то какой будет у человека день с точки
зрения просто настроение
я вот хотел вот именно про контент То
есть это же в общем вот для
контент-мейкеров
относиться к эту как положительному
процессу То есть у нас как вначале
конечно было очень много это но я до сих
пор эту практику Я практически после
выпуска до 12 Ну как бы где-то четыре
часа сижу в комментариях из каждым
каждому комментарию отвечаю есть это
очень эффективный очень эффективный
метод продвижения то есть грубо говоря
если тебе кто-то написал хорошую вещь Ты
ему хотя бы Рахмет пишешь Нет
свое внимание он уделил свое внимание
тебе
внимание сколько надо времени нет это
когда выпуск выходит на где-то 2-3 часа
на начальном этапе
потом есть хейтеры конструктивные если
ты конструктивному хейтеру отвечаешь
также конструктивно если ты ждал Здесь
был не прав в следующий раз исправим он
превращается в твоего фаната следующий
раз он будет писать также потом Ну то
есть если ты внимаешь уделяешь внимание
как бы аудитории конструктивной то у
тебя комментарии больше подписчиков
больше я активности больше
соответственно просмотр
хороший инструмент во-вторых
говорим о внимании
о чем ты думаешь чему ты посвящаешь
внимание А вы становится больше вначале
тоже загонялся когда плохие комментарии
я прям писал где-то ругался с ними но я
потом посмотрел у меня оказывается 90
комментариев два Спасибо я отвечаю им и
негатива становится больше я получается
положительно пропускаю отвечаю негативно
я решил использовать другую сторону то
есть я наоборот отвечаю положительным
негативным не отвечаю то есть совсем
такие безбожные негатичные люди потом
которые даже на негатив начинают
отвечать как фанаты я не согласен с Вами
фанаты становятся
То есть если какой-то неконструктивный
негатив Я просто пропускаю и не увидев в
твоей реакции он сам угасает Уже
понимает что бесполезно писать просто
беспочвенных бесполезно если почва есть
конструктив есть он получит
конструктивный ответ потом еще один
лайфхак наверное нас люди в любом случае
Прежде чем зайти посмотреть контент на
Ютубе по крайней мере они заходят читают
комментарии
потом только
то есть мы одно время практиковали такое
то есть Давайте так сделаем ребята
Жандос ермекер кевлар Абзал просто
Напишите от себя хорошую 5 коммент они
написали хорошие 5 коммент
зашел посмотрел тут хорошие комменты
надо посмотреть и он дальше тоже уже
увидев правильные комменты у него как бы
снижается желание писать плохое Но это
психологическая такая если там много
очень хейта Он еще не добавить
у любого события явление существует и
положительная сторона отрицательная и
когда
у вас много хейта Вы всегда должны
понимать что да первое положительное это
то что вы вызвали в людях реакцию
совершенно это очень важно потому что
самое худшее Если ваше творение вызывает
безразличие безразлично это худшее что
можно Потому что ты не можешь
усовершенствовать то на что нету реакции
усовершенствовать
ты понимаешь я я не пойду я значит иду
против тренда либо ты говоришь оба мне
надо это не делать делать все наоборот
что-то можешь с этим хейтом делать
поэтому хейт первое хорошая новость это
то что
ты вызвал реакцию причем бурную реакцию
а второй момент если вы монетизируете то
вы должны понимать что хейт увеличит
ваши продажи
Если вы политик Хей тоже не совсем плохо
потому что
однажды
[музыка]
семей Кеннеди то ли де то ли кто-то
сказал своему сыну губернатору говорит я
думал мой сын будет более лучшим
политиком чем я стал губернатором и так
далее
наблюдаю
ты даже не способен вызывать ненависть
То есть если
[музыка]
небольшой такой момент очень важный ко
мне один начинающий блогер подходил и
говорит моргает речь я вот что делаю и
видать ягод что-то не так высказал и
меня сейчас захейт или говорит
женщины захейтили его там видать он
что-то сексистская сказала ничего
больше защищаешь тем хуже Мне становится
меня забрасывает и так далее Что мне
делать игру А зачем ты вообще
защищаешься оправдываешься он говорит Ну
как же репутация и так далее на что ему
тогда сказал ты знаешь если ты вынужден
защищать свою репутацию то скорее всего
ее у тебя нет
Потому что когда у тебя есть репутация у
тебя нет необходимости защищать ее Вот
например если Вы меня знаете да и про
меня кто-то плохо говорит зачем
свою репутацию вы знаете меня значит
есть репутация если ее нет то бесполезно
защищать ее нет
[музыка]
поэтому говорю просто Продолжай дальше
свою линию если не прав лучше Извините
признайся и продолжаем гнуть свою линию
Да вот конструктивно хотят Когда тебе
что-то пишет плохое ты говоришь Хорошо
помоги как нам сделать дальше Вот это
хороший ход потому что реально среди
зрителей
Вы должны понимать что это очень важно
то есть у нас Частенько бывает такое что
хейтер он тебе говорит слушайте Ребята
надо сделать так-то надо использовать
наоборот когда ты обращаешься к этому
как помощнику
ты делаешь продукт лучше на самом деле
не такая активная К сожалению Даже когда
ты спрашиваешь что вам понравилось Дайте
фидбэк люди очень даже ленивые на это
стали для бизнеса как такового фидбэк
улучшение А вообще считается что даже
клиент который оставил
отзыв он на самом деле намного лояльный
к своим бизнесу и надо на него потратить
больше маркетинговых денег нежели на
привлечение нового клиента считается
лучше отработать Потому что сейчас цена
на привлечение клиента очень высокая
соответственно тебе легче проработать с
текущими скажем так подписчиками
клиентами неважно нежели с новыми Я
просто опережаю комментарии обязательно
напишите что Зори перебивает всех
поэтому хейтеры
я вызываю вас эмоции любовь
[смех]
к сожалению наше время подходит концу
давайте я подведу заключение
тема очень интересная можно говорить
очень много и долго тем более с такими
интересными собеседниками
[смех]
благодарность своим подписчикам нас
будет скоро миллион уже почти миллион
может уже в это время миллион Когда вы
смотрите этот подкаст
поэтому большая благодарность что вы
следите за мной за моими гостями и так
далее хотел бы выразить большую
благодарность Всем участникам очень
интересные участники собеседники приятно
прям такое было общение такое вайп
хочется сидеть дольше больше говорить
обо всем не только социальных сетях
личном бренды и так далее Спасибо
большое той команде большой команде
которая делает этот выпуск Итак пока
пока Всем до встречи на следующих
выпусках
[смех]
[музыка]